-Elle aurait pu rester médecin
à l'hôpital d'Orléans,
d'autant qu'elle s'est toujours
méfiée des partis politiques,
mais pour mener la mission
qu'elle s'est fixée,
elle s'est engagée en 2017
sous les couleurs d'En Marche.
Générique
...
Bonjour, Stéphanie Rist.
-Bonjour.
-Vous siégez aujourd'hui
à Renaissance.
Quand vous avez envoyé
votre CV à En Marche en 2017,
vous étiez persuadée
que vous ne seriez pas retenue.
Pourquoi ?
-Oui, je croyais
que les dés étaient jetés
à l'avance, que les postes
étaient déjà pourvus.
-Vous aviez une image
de la politique
pas formidable,
pour penser ça.
-Oui, en tout cas
que c'était réservé à certains,
soit parce qu'ils étaient engagés
très tôt dans des partis
ou soit parce qu'ils avaient fait
des études pour ça.
Voilà.
-L'idée d'être engagée
dans un parti,
c'était pas votre truc ?
-Non, j'étais pas engagée
dans un parti,
même si la chose politique
et la politique, les débats,
m'intéressaient déjà.
-A l'époque, vous étiez médecin
à l'hôpital d'Orléans.
Vous aviez jamais fait de politique,
mais vous l'avez emporté largement
aux législatives de 2017,
et le lendemain,
vous étiez confiante.
-Vous êtes novice.
Qu'est-ce qui fait que vous allez
être une bonne députée ?
-J'ai un engagement
qui est ancien,
à l'intérieur de l'hôpital,
en milieu associatif,
et il se poursuit.
Pour moi, c'est une continuité
sur mon parcours.
Certes, j'ai pas d'expérience
politique pure, mais j'ai
une expérience de l'écoute,
du partage, de l'échange
et de faire avancer les sujets.
-C'est surprenant.
Vous considérez
que votre mandat de députée
est la suite logique
de votre engagement de médecin.
-C'était cohérent.
Je travaillais à l'intérieur
de l'hôpital
pour améliorer l'accès
aux soins de mon territoire,
en difficulté en raison
du nombre de médecins
depuis de nombreuses années,
et j'étais arrivée au bout
de ce que je pouvais faire
à mon échelle
en tant que médecin.
Donc j'avais envie
de m'engager pour améliorer
l'accès aux soins.
-C'était déjà votre objectif
en présentant votre candidature ?
-Oui, c'était le sens premier
de mon engagement, pour améliorer
la vie des gens
sur l'accès aux soins.
C'est mon domaine de compétence.
-On va en parler
plus en longueur,
mais d'abord, sur le papier,
médecine et politique,
ça semble éloigné.
Vous voyez des points communs ?
-Oui, beaucoup.
J'avais peur que la médecine
me manque, en arrêtant,
même si je fais encore
une demi-journée.
Mais dans la politique,
vous continuez à écouter les gens
et à essayer d'améliorer leur vie,
soit localement à la permanence,
et vous essayez de les aider,
soit même nationalement
et dans les lois qu'on peut porter
ou voter.
On essaye d'améliorer la vie.
-Il y a une partie diagnostic
et une partie soins.
-Il y a une grosse partie écoute.
Je crois qu'il faut aimer les gens,
si on veut faire de la politique,
sinon, ça ne marche pas.
-Qu'est-ce qui est le plus facile
d'entre les deux ?
-Entre la médecine
et la politique ?
Je crois que la politique,
c'est énormément de travail.
Ca m'a surpris, d'ailleurs,
la quantité de travail
que font tous les députés.
Il y a beaucoup d'engagement
et de travail. La médecine aussi,
évidemment.
J'ai beaucoup travaillé
pendant mes études.
Mais en politique,
peut-être encore plus.
-Quand on regarde le bilan
de votre action depuis 2017,
presque toutes vos initiatives
sont tournées vers le fait
d'améliorer l'accès aux soins.
Vous êtes à l'origine de deux lois
qui ont été votées sur ce sujet.
Ca donne l'impression d'une députée
en mission. Vous vous retrouvez
dans cette formule ?
-Je sais pourquoi je suis là
et je sais pourquoi je suis engagée.
Et en même temps,
chacun doit apporter
sur les sujets dans le cadre
de ses compétences, dans son vécu,
ses expériences.
Moi, je m'engage sur la santé
et je travaille beaucoup
pour essayer d'améliorer les choses.
-Donc vous vous intéressez pas
ou peu au reste ?
C'est pas votre truc ?
-Non, et ça, c'est venu
progressivement.
Quand je suis arrivée,
j'étais pas dans la commission
des affaires sociales mais
dans celle des affaires culturelles,
donc je me suis tout de suite
intéressée à d'autres sujets,
même si je rapportais
souvent à la santé.
C'est bien sûr sur tous les textes,
parce que la vie des gens,
c'est pas que des problèmes
de santé, mais ma spécificité
est sur la santé.
-Pendant le débat sur la réforme
des retraites,
vous avez été rapporteur
de ce projet de loi.
On vous a vue répondre
aux différentes attaques
des oppositions sur une registre
purement politique,
sauf une fois,
en réponse au député
Rassemblement national
Thomas Ménagé.
On va revoir les images.
-Mon père a travaillé toute sa vie
sur les toits, il est couvreur.
Il a 58 ans aujourd'hui.
Chaque soir, ses genoux
doublent de volume.
Le matin, il est incapable
de se lever car il est cassé !
Venez sur le terrain
et vous comprendrez
que pour une partie des Français,
il est impossible d'aller à 64 ans.
-Monsieur Ménager,
mon père, il tenait un bistrot.
Il se levait à 5h du mat',
il bossait 7 jours sur 7.
Personne ici a un monopole
du papa qui a souffert
dans sa vie.
Huées
-C'est rare que les députés
parlent d'eux-mêmes,
de leur vie familiale,
on peut dire.
Pourquoi vous avez fait ça
ce jour-là ?
-Il faut remettre dans le contexte
d'une réforme compliquée
qui nécessitait beaucoup
de travail avant,
et aussi une fatigue
assez importante.
Je crois que dans ces moments-là,
finalement, on retire un peu
les barrières,
et c'était une attaque...
-Vous avez eu besoin
d'aller sur ce registre ?
-C'était d'une violence importante,
dans cette réforme des retraites,
avec des propos très virulents
de plusieurs... De plusieurs bords.
Et en fait, je trouve
que l'argument
était personnel et qu'il fallait
répondre par du personnel.
En fait, c'est sorti tout seul.
Je sais pas si à froid,
j'aurais eu
les mêmes arguments.
Je crois pas.
-Vous avez été élevée,
éduquée, dans un milieu
plutôt modeste, on l'a compris.
En choisissant médecine,
vous avez fait
les études les plus longues
en France.
Vous dites que c'était
une forme
de revanche.
Une revanche sur quoi ?
-Oui, j'ai des parents
qui ont tout mis...
On est deux filles,
et ils ont mis les études
comme quelque chose
d'important et émancipateur.
-Eux-mêmes n'ont pas fait d'études ?
-Eux-mêmes n'ont pas eu le bac.
Voilà, mais on n'en est pas tristes,
dans la famille.
Je suis très fière de mes parents.
Mais n'empêche
que la notion
de faire des études
et d'avoir cette chance
de pouvoir étudier
était vraiment rabâchée
presque tous les jours.
Avec ma soeur, on a fait
des études très longues,
et c'est peut-être en revanche
par rapport à eux.
-Vous avez choisi médecine,
mais la politique
vous a passionnée dès vos 7 ans.
Vous regardiez
"L'heure de vérité"
quand la plupart
des enfants regardaient
"Le Club Dorothée."
-On regardait "L'heure de vérité"
avec mon père et on préparait
vraiment l'émission,
et on débattait
sur les sujets.
J'essayais d'avoir un avis...
-C'était l'idée du débat
qui vous intéressait ?
-Oui.
C'était se positionner,
avoir un avis sur les choses
qui nous entourent, sur la société.
C'est pour ça que le sujet,
en politique, pour moi,
n'est pas que la santé,
mais tout m'intéresse,
pour porter un avis et convaincre.
-C'est peut-être pour ça
qu'à l'hôpital,
vous êtes un peu sortie
du cadre médicale,
comme vous l'expliquiez.
A 41 ans, vous avez fait
un Master
à Sciences Po,
c'était peut-être une façon
de vous rapprocher
de l'engagement politique,
mais le déclic a peut-être
eu lieu un peu avant.
Vous dites :
"Plus je regardais LCP,
"plus j'avais envie d'y aller."
Donc vous seriez peut-être pas
à l'Assemblée sans LCP ?
-Je sais pas, mais en tout cas,
je regardais
"Les questions au gouvernement",
mais aussi les séances la nuit
et je me disais :
"Ils sont pas très nombreux.
"si j'y étais,
j'y serai tout le temps."
-Depuis, vous avez changé
votre façon de voir les choses ?
-On comprend pourquoi
tous les sièges ne sont pas remplis,
parce qu'il y a des commissions,
des réunions.
C'est des choses
qu'on ne sait pas forcément
quand on regarde la télé.
-Peu de députés ont réussi
à donner leur nom
à deux lois en si peu de temps.
Vous avez fait voter
des mesures concrètes pour la santé,
comme le plafonnement des
salaires des médecins intérimaires
à l'hôpital, mais vous dites
avoir été surprise par la difficulté
à faire bouger les choses
en politique.
Comment vous expliquez cette forme
d'inertie qui peut exister ?
-Elle s'explique d'une part
pour une bonne raison
et une moins bonne.
La bonne raison,
c'est à mon avis
qu'il faut emmener tous les acteurs,
et quand vous touchez
à un sujet en politique,
ça touche les finances,
ça touche d'autres secteurs,
donc vous avez tous ces gens-là
à essayer d'emmener
vers une transformation
ou une politique qui change.
C'est normal que ça prenne du temps.
Et il y a aussi une lourdeur
administrative,
au changement culturel, aussi,
et parfois,
on aimerait que ça aille plus vite,
mais c'est notre boulot d'essayer
de faire accélérer
et bouger les lignes.
-Donc la résistance au changement,
en ce qui vous concerne,
elle est venue en grande partie
de vos propres collègues médecins,
qui ont pas été franchement
tendres avec vous.
C'est pas blessant de se battre
pour améliorer l'accès aux soins
et d'être accusée
par une partie
de la profession
d'être une traître ?
-C'est difficile au début,
en plus,
quand on est médecin,
les gens vous aiment bien.
En consultation le lundi matin,
les gens m'aiment bien.
Quand vous arrivez
en politique, vous comprenez
qu'il y a des gens
pas d'accord avec vous
et certains qui ont une violence.
Les lois que j'ai portées
sont des lois
qui changent la culture,
qui bousculent.
Ca a été peut-être un peu rapide.
Il y a eu aussi
des fausses informations,
tout ce qu'on retrouve
dès qu'on veut transformer
et faire avancer un peu plus vite.
Effectivement,
il y a des propos très violents.
Quand on s'attaque
au député lui-même...
Le premier truc qu'on vous dit
en politique, c'est :
"Ca va être dur."
Mais quand ça touche la famille,
c'est vraiment plus difficile.
-Dans les manifestations
des médecins libéraux,
il y a eu parfois
la pancarte "Rist tue",
et vous expliquez
que votre fille est tombée
face à cet affichage dans la rue.
-Il y avait un rassemblement
avec cette affiche dans ma ville,
et ma fille, avec ses copines,
sont passées pas loin en voyant ça.
Pour elle, c'était pas évident,
mais en même temps,
elle commence à être
un peu habituée.
Ca leur fait aussi se rendre compte
de ce que peut être l'engagement,
même s'il faut pas cautionner
cette personnalisation.
Quand vous faites une loi...
Certes, la loi porte mon nom,
j'étais à l'initiative,
mais on est aussi une majorité,
puisque ce sont des lois votées
par presque l'ensemble
de l'Assemblée.
-On va passer à notre quiz.
Je vais vous proposer
un début de phrase
et ça va être à vous
de la compléter.
On y va.
"En devenant députée,
"j'ai découvert que...
-Qu'il fallait
beaucoup travailler pour faire
bouger les lignes.
-Vous l'évoquiez.
"Depuis que je suis élue,
"ma famille me dit souvent..."
-"Continue."
-Malgré les attaques ?
-Oui.
-Malgré leur propre exposition ?
-Oui, j'ai posé
la question pour savoir
si je retournais
pour un deuxième mandat
et ça a été unanime.
-"Pour être ministre
"de la Santé, il faut..."
-Le vouloir.
Pour ma part, c'est pas ce qui
me fait me lever le matin.
Ce qui me fait me lever,
c'est améliorer les choses.
S'il faut passer par là,
pourquoi pas ?
-Votre nom a circulé
plusieurs fois.
-C'est normal, je m'occupe
des sujets santé.
Je cherche pas un poste
en particulier.
Je cherche à avancer les sujets,
mais ça passe par des postes.
-On verra pour la suite.
Merci
d'avoir été notre invitée.
-Merci beaucoup.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
Générique
...